neural scaling laws
excellent and that's great to go after
Greg actually because he set me up so
nicely
um
okay so uh I just wanted to like start
with some uh philosophy
or physics data is the dark matter of
theory and deeper
like we we can't hope to understand what
deep learning is doing if we don't have
an understanding of what we're asking
deep learning to do and what we're
asking deep learning to do is
fundamentally embedded in the data
because that determines creating loss
and so forth and so you know just as in
other domains nothing in biology makes
sense except in line about
neuroscience
to other people I'd like to become
famous someday so I wanted to add
something this is my quote not chapter
nothing in deep learning makes sense
except in light of the structure of the
data it's not quite as pithy and
probably won't be famous but anyway I
still think it's true
so now this is a problem right because
our lack of understanding of the data oh
are you saying the light coming through
the lens on
oh sorry the the thing wasn't on okay
um
our lack of understanding of the data is
becoming a fundamental problem for
example in some cases we don't even know
what the training data is like in gpt4
yet we do see remarkable new
capabilities for example solving exams
but I'm sure once you saw this your
immediate question that you asked was
well to what extent are the problem
questions on these exams already in the
web
and these things trained on the entire
web right so so how surprised should we
be by these new capabilities when the
pre-training set is the entire internet
of say text and code
and and even and it you know I don't
think it's the case that it's just
copying stuff it's it's really combining
things in really interesting ways to
answer interesting questions but even if
we know what the pre-training data set
is how different really are the tasks
that are performed at say test time like
in conscious learning tasks how
different really are they from things
that we're seeing during pre-training
right we don't really have a good
understanding of that
um so we're going to ask kind of two
questions uh especially about the
diversity of the pre-training set
for example how diverse is the
pre-training set need to be to enable
new capabilities like in context
learning of new tasks and how different
can the new tasks be seen how different
can the new tasks be
from the pre-training data right and
also uh you know neural scaling laws
we've seen several talks on that here
um you know performance scales with the
amount of data but does the quality of
the data matter or the diversity of the
data matter and if we can create more
diverse data can we beat these neural
scaling laws so that'll be the the
second part so basically uh this talk is
kind of two parts uh the first part
builds actually off of what Greg was
talking about so we're going to focus on
uh in context learning of regression but
the reason we do that is to really sort
of address try to address this question
in a more in a controlled setting right
by focusing on regression we can one
Define a space of tasks two we can
define a metric on the space of tasks
that allows us to quantitatively assess
how different a new task is from the set
of pre-training tasks we can
parametrically vary the pre-training
data or task diversity
um uh in a controlled manner we can
derive optimal Bayesian in context
Learners under different priors and we
can quantitatively understand
Transformer performance in relation to
these various Vision Learners so we can
sort of really understand what's going
on and what we're going to find is we're
going to find a phase transition in
which in which in context learning
suddenly emerges at a threshold task
diversity in the pre-training set and
this emerging capability cannot be
explained by Bayesian learning with the
pre-training task distributions of Prior
so there have been various approaches to
try to explain in context learning as as
just page and inference but it turns out
that's not the case it's actually a
failure of Asian inference here that
leads to a good in context loading of
new tasks and then in the second part
we're going to show that the slow power
loss scaling of performance with respect
to data set size indicates that data is
actually highly redundant and by finding
non-redundant more diverse data sets we
can significantly outperform these
existing neural scaling models
so let's get started and so both of
these Works have been recently
um at least on the on the archive or
have been published so the first is this
paper pre-training task diversity and
the emergence of non-invasion and
context of regression it's worked on by
three really talented grad students Alan
menshee and Fang
okay so um so this is so we're gonna
um have the same setup that Greg talked
about so it'll look familiar but the
notations of course all different
um but but we're going to do some twists
on the on the distributions okay so so
what is a single task uh for regression
we're defining a single task
to be an unknown regression Vector in D
dimensional space
you get K input output pairs so the X's
are inputs y's are outputs the Y could
just be a scalar
um we're going to draw the a single
unrun regression Vector from an
isotropic gaussian and d-dimensional
space the input will also be isotropic
gaussian and the output will be labeled
by the true regression Vector of plus
noise so we're going to work in a noisy
regression setting and so this is just a
d equals one dimensional example
now
context learning a problem for a
Transformer we're going to do it the
same way we're going to do it auto
aggressively so we're going to have a
Transformer here
we're going to feed in the context here
is a sequence of input output input
output drawn from some task so there's
some unknown regression Vector W that
relates the Y's to the X's here
okay
and now we're going to have a whole a
sequence of contexts so for each context
at a k of context
it sees the first K minus 1 input output
pairs
and then it sees a new KF input and it's
got to get the right output for the KF
input based on the knowledge of the
context of the previous K minus one
input output pairs so for example here's
uh context k equals two you see input
one output one input two and its task is
to come up with a prediction for Y2 it
hasn't seen Y2 yet that'll appear in the
next context and so it's all done Auto
aggressively
the loss function just squared loss on
the outputs in sequence all right so
okay so so that I mean that's what we're
going to do in context but where do we
get this Transformer from we pre-train
it on a distribution of of
um tasks right so this is the
pre-training process so here here's
where we start to make some departures
here's where we parametric control the
task diversity in the pre-training data
distribution so imagine we have a
pre-training data distribution where
there's a fixed number of M capital M
unknown tasks
and and they're drawn once and for all
from an isotropic gaussian but then
they're fixed
so this is our kind of limited task
diversity and M is the pre-training task
diversity parameter
and the pre-training loss function that
we're going to use to derive our
Transformer waves is just this loss
function
basically we choose a w from a uniform
distribution over these M discrete task
vectors right and then we draw random
inputs random noise and we of course get
the labels and then we minimize the
squared loss for all different context
lines
so okay but then for actual pre-training
we estimate this expectation as we
usually do in machine learning
uh we construct a mini batch okay and we
sample some number of of examples this
way and then and we take a gradient
descent step with respect to the loss
function on that mini batch and we
iterate many many times right so this
whole pre-training process it's going to
see lots and lots of different inputs
and outputs right but they're all going
to be derived from a finite set of task
vectors right so that's like a data set
that's uh not very rich in terms of its
content right but ideally we'd like to
do in context learning a fundamentally
new tasks that are different from any of
the tasks that were seen during
pre-training okay so that's our goal so
then how do we assess that in context
learning so now what we do is we have a
um
a new task Vector drawn from
um just the an isotropic gaussian
distribution so it's like a sphere in
high dimensions
right and the laws that are completely
new task is is the same thing except the
the distribution of pre-training tasks
is replaced with the true distribution
of our tasks right
and so this loss function measures a
performance of fundamentally new tasks
now um
what are some theoretical limits that
are interesting to compare are
Transformer to okay the one is the the
Bayesian approach right which is just
says like you know like in Prior
theories of income tax learning let's
just consider a Bayesian learner that
learns
the distribution of tasks in the
pre-training data because that's all it
ever has X that's all the Transformer
ever has access to the distribution of
tasks in the pre-training data okay
we're going to assume because we we
train the transformer for so long
we're going to assume that the
Transformer could or we don't even have
to make that assumption that the to
motivate this this uh algorithm we can
think of the Transformer as implicitly
learning the M finite regression vectors
that were hidden in the in all the input
output examples that it got
and then if it were to know that we
could ask what would a ideal Bayesian
Observer do or Beijing estimator do if
it knew the M pre-training task of
vectors and it needed to predict the
output to some new input well what we
could do is we could just uh compute the
posterior mean of the output given the
context and the M task vectors and
that's a very easy posterior mean to
compute if you compute it it looks like
you're effectively Computing a
regression
you're Computing a regression estimate
where the estimated regression Vector is
just a weighted average of the unknown
of the of the regression vectors in your
pre-training distribution weighted by
the likelihood that they were to make
the prediction that was observed right
so roughly it's like a abasian estimator
that has memorized these these uh M
vectors and it uses them in an optimal
way in the minimum mean squared error
sense to predict the output to Any Given
sequence of context if you have no data
to begin with then you just take the
average of all of your regression
vectors so all of you could do this
calculation in a few lines right of
course so we call this the discrete
minimum mean squared estimator because
it's it's a it's the mmse estimator if
you know the the you if you know the
prior distribution over this discrete
set of tasks
um so here if you uh
um
if you only saw each task like once yeah
then yeah we don't work in that setting
so that's another big difference from
from the way you guys do it you see each
one many many times
uh I'll show you the numbers on the next
slide on a couple of slides when I show
you so basically you have you have like
M tasks
oh I mean yeah so when you construct a
mini batch you choose for each member of
the mini batch you choose one of the W's
from the set of mw's and you choose a
fresh set of inputs and a fresh set of
outputs yeah so you're seeing many many
different inputs and outputs there's no
repetition there that's like one Epoch
inputs and outputs sure but it's
multi-epbook and the unknown regression
vectors or tasks that's like it's like
saying I'm gonna sample as many
um Wikipedia articles as I can but
they're always going to be Wikipedia
articles and they're never going to be
Shakespeare right yeah no no I guess as
this this notion of uh the the bay is
optimal sort of estimator I guess here
it does sort of make sense because the
Transformer could sort of understand the
distribution with respect to what yeah
optimal although if you know if you sort
of formulated it as like
um
yeah if there's a bit of uncertainty
into like whether or not you actually
ever you include one of these tasks
then you know it's sort of uh yeah I
actually tried another
um
theoretical approximation which is the
noisier noise discrete MMC where you you
you you get a noise but your prior is a
noise ball around each of these tasks
and that interpolate as you increase the
noise that interpolates between this and
Ridge and it never quite explained what
the Transformer does but interestingly
these two things that I'm about to show
you explain what the Transformer does in
two different settings we'll get into
all of that soon
okay now the other option is just what
if you knew the true distribution of
tasks to be an isotropic gaussian
and then you have gaussian noise and all
that then what's the mmsc estimator
there right well we all know that that's
rich regression where the ridge
parameter is set by the noise in of your
outputs right
okay so this is the ridge estimator and
um this will do really really well on
new tasks the dmmsc will do really
really well in the pre-training test
distribution but it will not do well in
new tasks okay so now the natural
question is well what does the
Transformer do and how does what it
learns depend on the task diversity
parameter end the pre-training task
diversity parameter app
okay just one more measure of what the
Transformer is doing we can also compute
the distance in prediction space
between the function learned by the
Transformer and these two interesting
functions right a ridge or dmmse and so
there we just take the output of the
Transformer the squared difference
between
um the prediction of say either Ridge or
dmmc whichever one you're using at the
moment and and we average it over the
true task distribution right and of
course a random distribution of inputs
and outputs and so this just tells you
how far is the function learned by the
Transformer from either Ridge or dmmse
and we'll plot that in in future figures
okay so now let's look at our first
results so there's there's a bunch of
things to unpack here okay so on this
horizontal axis is the pre-training task
diversity right this is the parameter M
it ranges from two to two to the 20th or
so
okay
the vertical axis is the error on the
final example so I could show you these
these Auto aggressive curves
um that Greg we're showing you
um
but uh but I'm just showing you the
final final error as as an example the
final error is non-trivial because
there's noise so so it can be non-zero
um Okay so
let's just look at the performance of
dmmsc and ridge so dmmsc is the green
one right
so if you are evaluating the error on
the pre-training task distribution
then dmmsc is the best you can do so the
green curve is always the lowest
and of course the absolute error Rises
as you get more and more tasks right
because I um yeah
the ridge does worse on the pre-training
test division relative to dmmse because
the dmmc knows the exact M task vectors
that were in the pre-trained
distribution which doesn't it just knows
a isotropic prior
right so a rich will do worse of course
as the number of pre-training task
distributions becomes really really
large gmmse and ridge should approach
each other okay that's what's expected
what does the Transformer do that's
that's this orange line
it behaves exactly like uh dmmsc at load
task diversity right so it's as if the
Transformer is somehow memorizing The
Limited diversity in the pre-training
set
but after the amount of pre-training
diversity grows beyond a certain
threshold it can see it no longer can do
that and then eventually it snaps into
what Ridge can do despite the fact that
there isn't that much task diversity uh
at the point where the Transformer snaps
into Ridge
right so interestingly the Transformer
is failing to minimize its pre-training
loss but when it fails it fails an
interesting way it becomes rich and
it'll do well in new tasks okay now
let's evaluate so this was all
evaluating performance on the
pre-training test distribution let's
look at the same performance in the true
task distribution so this is like how
well does each algorithm solve new tasks
that are not in the pre-training
so Ridge now is the best thing you can
possibly do right so rich does really
really well
okay dmmsc does really poorly right at
low task diversity and then eventually
it'll it'll approach rage and then
here's the same snap in behavior of the
Transformer it behaves like dmmsc on on
uh new tasks so it cannot solve new
tasks well and then eventually it snaps
into Ridge and now it cancels new tasks
as well okay uh just some numbers it's a
gp2 art gpt2 architecture the input
Dimension was eight
um we had a batch size of 256 and 500k
training steps so that's like a 128
million examples so you're seeing you
know you're seeing these however many
tasks many many times because we're
taking 100 we're taking 128 million
gradients or
uh we're seeing 128 million task
examples
okay now a natural question is well what
if we were to train for a longer oh
sorry go ahead does the does the size of
the Transformer affect how long it will
continue to pave like yeah we'll we'll
talk about that in the future slot yeah
yeah is there any relation with like
pseudorandom generators right if I have
a Subspace of items but it's kind of
hard to distinguish it from uh
of what the larger space of more uniform
we could play with that with interest
more interesting distributions over true
regression vectors w we haven't tried
that idea uh yeah yeah is is the red
curve can you think of it as the base
optimal
um estimator for the distribution where
um you know you have this set of of uh
of tasks but each task you never see
examples from it with some tiny
probability 0.01
we haven't tried that what we did try
was
you get a noisy estimate of each task
that's like the smooth discrete intimacy
and that algorithms learning curve even
if you optimize the noise doesn't match
this orange curve so we can't
approximate what the Transformer is
doing at least in terms of performance
with that heuristic estimator sure
this is
is too large then you need to then like
just do regression otherwise not to one
of these tasks yeah exactly yeah yeah it
seems so maybe at low task diversity it
kind of explains what's going on in the
transform
so at least for this small number of
tasks the Transformer can acts as if it
knows what the each of the tasks are
designed so it's like it's like it
sounds to me if you train for solution
to the number of steps
the Transformer should fit the uh
creators
if you keep training okay that's a good
question that's exactly what we're going
to ask next
to be true
there's a shift from the green
the Bluetooth it seems like you are
doing early stopping so you get a rich
like behavior I'm not sure if that is
the right understanding we are yeah
we're not doing early stuff I mean the
like the number of training staff is
fixed but the number of times so we're
gonna increase it exactly so we're gonna
vary that right let me show you what
happens when we vary that and if that
doesn't answer your question we can come
back to it
okay so that that's where these red
arrows are coming in right so we've we
trained for 500k steps right what would
happen if we train for longer right what
would happen of course dmmsc and ridge
won't train it won't change there's no
training involved in those
um what will happen to the Transformer
uh it turns out that the performance
will become more like Ridge if the task
diversity is high and become more like
dmmse if the task diversity is low which
means that this transition will become
sharper if we train for longer so let me
show you the evidence for that so what
are different ways that we can train for
longer right we could keep all the hyper
parameters of trading the same but
increase the batch size
so here the batch size was 256. so we
increased it to 512 and then to 10 24.
and what we found so this blue is the
smallest batch size that's what you've
seen before oh and this axis the
distance from the pre-trained
Transformer to Ridge in the prediction
space so it's just a measure of how
close is the pre-train Transformer to
Ridge as a function right
so you see that uh over here if you
train for longer or trained with more
data at the same fixed cost diversity
then what happens is at a threshold task
diversity if you're up up here at high
task diversity you actually become more
and more like Ridge
right even though you're training with
more data and a fixed number of tasks
you don't get closer to dmmc you get
closer to Ridge
however low task diversity
if you increase the amount of data you
get further away from bridge and it
turns out that you get closer to dmmse
right
okay another way that you could increase
the um amount of training is just keep
the batch size the same but increase the
number of training steps that's right
let's say we go from half a million
training steps to a million training
steps you get a similar um pattern at a
similar threshold right again so at high
task diversity
more training makes the PT more like
Ridge that would do well in new tasks
but at low test diversity the pre-train
Transformer PT becomes less like Ridge
on mute tasks
so so this is what we use to define a
task diversity threshold it's the
threshold that demarcates these two
phases where if I train more I become
more like Ridge that's this phase and
here if I train more I become less like
rich
so yeah so here's this uh kind of the
space transition right so this
horizontal axis the task diversity
here's this task diversity threshold
here I become more like Ridge if I train
longer and here I become less likely to
put trademarks
so there is this algorithmic phase
transition in the pre-trained
Transformer at this task diversity
threshold red transitions from being
more like dmmc to more like Ridge if you
train longer that's the definition of
the of the transition
okay here's a direct demonstration of
the emergence of in-context learning
from your tasks so let's say I start
with my pre-training distribution and I
have you know a finite set of tasks so
this is the the D dimensional input
space these are the You Know M vectors
corresponding to the m true regression
vectors I could track the performance of
all three algorithms if I interpolate
between two uh pre-training task vectors
right so I um I generate new problem
instances where I interpolate the
regression Vector between two uh known
uh two regression vectors that are in
the pre-training distribution so new
tasks will be in the middle alphas and
interpolation parameter
and you see that um at low pre-training
task diversity so here's the Orange is
the pre-train Transformer it does really
well on the on the two tasks that had
already seen but it does terribly on new
tasks that it hadn't seen before but
Ridge of course always does well but it
does worse than dmmsc into the future in
the preacher and Transformer on tasks
that
they had both seen before right okay as
you increase the task diversity here you
suddenly see the the pre-trained
Transformer switches from dmmse to Ridge
also in this kind of uh context and then
you see that it behaves like Ridge so
now Ridge does a well on new tasks and
dmmsc doesn't do as well in new tasks
so
um so yeah so so that's kind of a direct
uh um
kind of visualization of how this thing
can learn new tasks
beyond the test diversity threshold
okay so okay now how does the task
diversity threshold scale with the input
Dimension right so the volume of tasks
is exponential in the input or task
Dimension right the way to think about
that is a an isotropic gaussian in high
dimensional spaces concentrates in a
sphere the surface area of that sphere
is exponential in the dimension
so you know for dmmse to really sample
all of the space it would need
exponentially many
um we need exponentially many uh task
vectors right
but then how does the task diversity
threshold scale with d right does the PT
also need to see exponentially many
tasks in pre-training to solve any new
task well
and it turns out it doesn't surprisingly
um so here we scaled the number of
Dimensions scaling the signal to noise
ratio the problem so it's always
constant
and um
and so we did the same experiment where
we increased the batch size and we asked
you become more like Ridge or less like
Ridge and that transition determines the
test diversity threshold and you can see
that when you go from 8 to 16 to 32
Dimensions you go from a test average
threshold just above to 14 to 2 to the
you know 16 so just above 2 to 16. so
roughly the scaling it's hard to do
these these training runs as you
increase the dimensions
but roughly at least for this limited
range we see that the scaling of task
diversity with a testamentally threshold
with Dimension appears favorable it
seems to be linear
we could ask the same thing about what
about dmmse well
we can't scale the number of tasks
exponentially with Dimensions we asked a
slightly different question for the
largest number of tasks that we looked
at 2 to the 20 tasks
right we computed the distance between
dmmse and ridge right as a function of
the dimension and you see as the
dimension gets larger gmmse gets further
and further from Ridge as you'd expect
right you have a finite set of tasks but
you're increasing the volume of the
sphere
so dmmsc doesn't behave like Ridge it
gets worse and worse as the dimension
increases but in this range of
Dimensions the pre-trained Transformer
has no such growth of distance to Ridge
it it really behaves like Ridge
um partially because the task diversity
threshold is somewhere around here
so the the scaling of the trade
pre-trained Transformer performance with
Dimension is vastly superior to what a
Bayesian uh in context learner would do
in this setting so again the emergence
of in context learning cannot be
explained by a Bayesian Theory with
respect to the pre-training task
distribution here yeah
we're going to get to that because like
we run through Banner rights
by Transformers title of the next slide
yeah yeah good question so
yeah I still think that uh this is is
optimal for prior which is
indistinguishable from uh you know with
respect to your prior it's not adoptable
but there's a prior with respect to
which uh it is optimal and you can't
distinguish the two cars from each other
um maybe we can talk about that later
it's not Bayes optimal with respect to
the true prior
Ridge is based optimism to the true
crier no no but with respect to the the
Distribution on widgets
like there is a prior with respect to
what it's uh like that's consistent with
it yeah but that prior has if it exists
has not been written down yet in this
talk but I don't know what that prior is
oh it's just it's just where there are
some of these true tasks
where there's some Azure you know where
you don't actually see it in any of your
back that's extremely unlikely in our
setting right like uh no no it doesn't
in your sitting uh but you can't if
you're just this model
you know yeah you see some finite number
of tasks yeah but um this prior that oh
like there are there might be some tasks
where I see them during times where I
see them a million times there's a small
probability to see them zero times that
is a valid prior that's consistent with
it yeah but you still have to prove that
it explains the pre-trained Transformer
Behavior right uh that's true but it's
probably that like I mean I would say
it's almost my intuitions are completely
opposite I would say it's by large
deviation Theory almost extremely
unlikely to because we're showing 128
million examples and we have like you
know two to the 10 tasks right so it's
extremely unlikely to never see examples
from one class extremely unlikely so how
could if some if an event that's
unlikely to happen in the pre-training
process but it's likely to happen a year
prior how could it explain what's going
on yeah let's talk afterwards yeah
yeah
it's growing like if you increase the
batch size by two the total amount of
training day goes by two basically and
what makes the transition
like you've just trained for longer
so amount of training you get at Sugar
weight
and his health fixed right so in these
in these plots so so the easiest one to
think about is the pre-training data
right the horizontal axis is the amount
of is the task diversity that's M right
so that's held fixed in fact everything
is held fixed except I'm just increasing
the batch signs which means I'm seeing
more examples for times
and then I ask do I become more like
Ridge or less likely
and here I become more like Ridge and
here I become less like rich
I do have intuition in terms of if I fix
the total amount of data then I want to
see like if I want to kind of think
about
about fixed amount of data I increase
the I increase M but then the number of
examples occurred
tasks
how does that
yeah I don't think we've done that
specific experiment but you can see
variations in M by by walking along
these curves right so this is
um I guess this is increase yeah this is
increasing M and decreasing number of
examples
that's what these cards are doing
oh no we haven't we have tried a LaPlace
prior and then it at high task adversity
the pre-trained Transformer behaves
Bayesian with respect to the LaPlace
prior uh over the whole space and at um
low test diversity it behaves like dmnc
again so you get the same behavior right
so
except it generalizes a little cost
prior so these pre-train Transformers
are really good
what's surprising here is that they're
really good but let me summarize a
surprise later like or emphasize it
maybe
um
okay the capacity question so it turns
out like for example with regularization
uh what these plots are telling you is
increased rate Decay reduces the task
diversity threshold so weight Decay is
somehow regularizing is of course
regular I mean chronologically
regularizing the training and what that
intuitively you might think that
prevents the pre-trained transformer for
memorizing The Limited number of tasks
and therefore at a lower task diversity
threshold it'll start to be able to
solve new tasks better and that's what
happens
increasing the model capacity does not
appreciably change the past diversity
threshold but we're already starting
from a pretty large model right it turns
out if you reduce the model capacity
um it increases the trans diversity
threshold so or sorry decreases the
potassium
oh sorry weight Decay means you you just
had a W Squared term to your lot so so
uh the gradient is minus W so you're
decaying all the weights
okay so now why where might this
algorithmic phase transition be coming
from what might be a mechanistic
explanation for it short answer is we
don't know but but I can give you our
current best guess okay we can try to
peek under the hood and look at the
pre-training learning Dynamics right we
never looked at that yet right so this
axis
is the number of pre-training steps
right up to 500k pre-training steps
these different colors are different
pre-training task diversities right so
so blue is low test diversity uh uh you
know pink is is um
High task diversity
uh and so forth right this is the
distance between the preachers so these
are not error learning curves but
they're distance learning curves the
distance from the pre-trained
Transformer to Ridge and function space
and prediction space
evaluated on a random distribution of
tasks drawn from the true distribution
of fast so this is measuring how close
are you to Ridge on just a isotropic
gaussian distribution attack so the most
general setting possible
okay and what happens in low task
diversity is initially the pre-trained
Transformer becomes closer to Ridge
and but then it it runs away and becomes
further away from Ridge and when it does
it becomes closer to dmmse it turns out
the same effect happens at a slightly
higher task diversity
if you lower the task diversity sorry if
you've increased the task diversity even
more you'll get this sudden transition
where the curves are monotonically
decreasing now
right
so now what's happening is that they
don't see the dmmsc solution they just
keep getting closer and closer to Ridge
they don't get trapped by the dmmse
solution
you might ask well what if I train for
longer right so this is what happens if
I if I um
4X the number of trading steps I go from
500k to 2 million and this dichotomy
between the two types of learning curves
is largely preserved around the same
task diversity threshold and that's the
same threshold that we've roughly two to
the 10 tasks yeah that changes so if you
keep training more I I would say like
the even more classical diversity you
still get away from yeah
potentially but I think it's very
unlikely I think this green curve is
right at the border so it's quite
sensitive and the purple curve is much
more stable you know if you train for
longer it still won't eventually go up
and I'll give you more evidence for why
right now okay
so so here's part of the evidence you
could ask how does the training time
scale with the task complexity okay so
we could just have a convenient measure
of this what might be considered an
optimal early stopping time when you're
closest to Ridge but by the way even
when you get closest to Ridge you're not
as good as Ridge so you can't use the
optimal early stopping time to get a
good pre-train Transformer that gives
you in context learning with new tasks
by just doing early stopping okay but
any case we can compute this uh turn to
Turning time we'll call it a t-star and
ask how does it scale with m
it turned so it turns out it scales as a
power law with M approximately with a
square root square root scaling right
until you get to this task diversity
threshold phase transition where
suddenly it jumps up I mean by
definition jumps up to you know it's a
500K year because it never turns around
right so now
um
if you were to suddenly like increase
the training time if this were not a
stable picture
what would have to happen is suddenly
this thing would have to drop down all
the way to here in order to match the
square root of scaling or some of the
scaling Law changes which both scenarios
seem pretty pretty unlikely
and we've done other experiments we've
done many many experiments now where we
increase the training time and we don't
see a huge difference in the task
diversity threshold
okay so what okay so so now here's kind
of the take-home message right
so as you increase the task diversity M
it takes longer and longer for the
pre-trained Transformer to stop moving
towards Ridge and eventually turn around
to dmmc until it never until beyond the
test diversity threshold it never finds
DMs
okay
um but here's the thing so dmmse is the
thing that minimizes the pre-training
law so that's what we're used to doing
like we want to figure out what
minimizes the pre-training loss now when
something doesn't minimize the
pre-training loss there could be
infinitely many ways it could
potentially underfit so there's many
many ways to fail right it's like all
failed machine learning models are
different in different ways the happy
ones are all the same right so um
so when the pre-trained Transformer
fails to minimize its pre-training loss
by failing to find dmmc it in some sense
interestingly enough fails in the best
possible way it finds Ridge which is
quite surprising
and it's precisely this failure of
pre-trading that allows the emergence of
in context learning of new tasks because
Ridge is fundamentally the algorithmic
can do uh new tasks yeah
this is failed to minimize the training
loss yep it does I mean that's what you
see well at least relative to dmmc
so so that's what we showed in the
beginning right the error of the you
know at high task diversity the error of
the pre-trained Transformer is higher
than the error of dmmse
so I'm going to give you a picture that
I think some that's at least consistent
with the data so far on the next slide
okay so okay so that this is an
important clue right when it fails to
find dmmc it finds Ridge
and there's a sudden transition between
between the two so what might be the
case so whenever there's a failure of
machine learning
uh to find the best possible solution to
the pre-training loss which in this
particular case is the mmsc there's two
potential reasons for the failure one is
an expressivity problem right there
might be no configuration or Transformer
weights that can realize demosc that
that might be true
um another possibility is it might be a
training failure there may be such a
configuration but it's Basin of
Attraction is so small that SGD cannot
find it right
um let's say it were the second
possibility what what might the space
transition look like in terms of a lost
landscape this is our current best guess
for it so at low pre-training task
diversity
this is the pre-training loss as a
function of the Transformer parameters
of cartoon
right there's a dmmse points and a Ridge
Point
and there's a global minimum at Ridge
that's wide enough that SGD can find it
okay and that's you know that's what we
see at low task diversity the
Transformer behaves like Ridge
at high task diversity what assuming the
dmmsc is is part of the
the set of accessible functions by the
Transformer there must be a minimum of
the pre-training loss at the mmsc but it
might be so sharp or have a basin of
Attraction that's so small
that SGD cannot find it and
interestingly there must be a second
Basin that's wide enough that's found
all the time
that has a minimum located at Ridge but
its error is higher than that of the MMC
and you can imagine just like in physics
there could be a first order phase
transition
where this thing as you increase the the
task diversity
this thing gets wider and develops a
minimum so sorry so it kind of Falls and
this thing becomes sharper and sharper
that's my best guess as to what happens
you can already imagine that this kind
of conceptual Theory suggests various
experiments do to further test this
hypothesis
but but this is what I think is
happening in the space transition
so um
okay so that's my last slide for the
first part are there any questions
here is the third case so if you take
the classical diversity to Infinity
issue the recovery
yeah that's right but that happens at
really really large app yeah so there
should be a circle it happens beyond the
M that we're considering at the moment
like Suddenly It's a barrier the uh
the barrier should disappear oh yeah
that's a good point that's a really good
point
um at really really large M there should
be one minimum that that's and and
that's located where dmmsc and ridge are
you're absolutely right but if you look
at like the regimes that we're looking
at here
there's still a gap there's still a gap
between dmmsc and ridge it's a small Gap
but there's a gap nonetheless but you're
absolutely right like a really really
large task diversity like everything's
simple
but what's really interesting
is that a really low tasks diversity
where there's a huge gap between dmmse
and Ridge
the pre-trained Transformer still
prefers Rich that's a surprising thing
it's it it can't find the DMV solution
it finds Ridge even when Rich and dmmc
are really far apart
and that's what I was trying to capture
in this
in this uh figure here dmoc and ridge
are far apart but somehow the
Transformer likes Rich again this is all
speculation this picture is all
speculation but it really is my best
guess as to what's going on and if we
were to continue working on this this
would guide the experiments of the team
this picture
thank you
yeah so some of your curves there looks
mirrorless and I'm a little curious as
to whether or not
it's not this one I'm not reference
looked
um either geometrics
oh so I'm trying to figure out the
characteristic of it
yeah I'm not sure okay
um okay I wanted to talk about another
setting uh I think I can go through the
highlights of this quickly
um we started late right like 10 minutes
late so
after okay perfect yeah so about 15
minutes okay so um
here's another setting where uh data
diversity matters it can actually change
the scaling laws uh that we observe in
practice
so um this is work done again by a very
talented team
um that's kind of a body of three papers
here
I'm going to focus mostly on this paper
but but this paper motivates
so here's the basic idea so some other
talks in this in this in this uh
Workshop we've looked at neural scaling
laws uh so that's where error tends to
fall off as a power law with either the
number of parameters the number of data
points or the amount of compute
but uh the exponent's often pretty small
right so I personally think advancing AI
through scaling alone
is a quite expensive it's definitely
expensive and there's a question as to
whether or not it's it's sustainable
right okay so for example if you do
language modeling with large
Transformers a drop in Cross entropy
from 3.4 now to 2.8 Nats requires sort
of 10x more training data right the
scaling exponent is minus 0.09 so it's
quite close to zero
um in large Vision Transformers a
similar thing if you want to go if you
go from one billion data points to two
billion data points you you can get a
two percent to three percent Improvement
in image net performance right so you're
kind of adding a billion data points
getting a two percentage Point
Improvement
okay so this is this is what I mean by
slow and unsustainable
okay so let me give you the key ideas
and take home messages in the second
part so the the key idea is that slow
power loss scaling of error with respect
to data set size likely indicates a
trading examples are highly redundant
right almost topologically adding more
examples doesn't help you very much so
they're somehow redundant
therefore we should be able to prune
data sets to identify sparse subsets of
non-redundant examples
um and because they're non-redundant
they're more diverse in some sense and
if we plot error as a function the size
of approved non-redundant data set then
we might be able to beat this power law
scaling
okay so what we do is we show
analytically that we we can do this for
the perceptron learning in a
student-teacher setting and there at
least we can achieve exponential scale
both in theory and practice okay and
then in practice in other settings uh
beyond the perceptron for example
resnet's trained on Benchmark tasks and
vision Transformers trained uh
pre-trained Imaging
we show um how to beat power law scaling
using these similar algorithms
we'll find that the way that we prune
the data matters so we perform a
benchmarking study of many different
pruning metrics we develop a new metric
that's cheap and scalable
um it doesn't even require labels to
compute so you can use it on unlabeled
data and then we can sort of prune to 75
of image without suffering any drop in
accuracy and then in later work we
showed how to apply this to language
models and and much larger internet
scale data sets in in this paper
so okay so how do we do this so so
what's a what's an interesting strategy
to prune a data set
well here's a simple heuristic that we
explored in this paper with machine and
Carolina
um so uh
what we did was we we trained
um
uh on a data set in this case cfar10 for
a very short period of time
right
and then for each individual example we
compute its distance to the decision
boundary
and those that are far from the decision
boundary and the correct side are in
some sense easy examples they can be
learned quickly and correctly
in a short amount of training time
those that are close to the decision
boundary or even worse on the opposite
side of District boundary and Far Away
these are the hard examples they're not
confidently learned or either incorrect
after a short period of training time
right so so we can we can rank examples
by their difficulty uh defined this way
okay we can we can do this a few times
to average the scores right and what we
can do is we can prune the data by
retaining only a fraction F of the
hardest examples
so then the question is how many
examples can you prune before suffering
any loss whatsoever and it turns out in
c410 we can prune about 50 of the
examples we can throw away half the data
set and if you train on that half data
set you do as well as if you train on
the entire data set and on C4 100 we can
we could throw away about 25 of the
dates
okay so this is a reasonable heuristic
pruning algorithm that it raises a bunch
of questions
why does data printing in this fashion
even work
why is keeping the hardest quote-unquote
hardest example is the right approach or
is it
can we develop a mathematical theory of
data protein
and how does performance scale with
prune data set science
and and more of a can we scale it up
would it work on image now or do we need
new ways of pruning for image
Okay so
what's our idea is we started from some
Theory uh actually so we just asked in
the simplest possible setting can we
analytically derive the test error after
pruning
so we started with the perceptron uh so
so so basically the the model of the
data distribution is as follows we pick
P IID random gaussian inputs
um
so we pick a random teacher perceptron
with with weight Vector T so here's your
teacher it has a decision boundary
perpendicular to the weight vector and
we label the examples just by the sign
of the dot product of the teacher with
each example so these examples are the
plus examples and these examples are the
minus examples so two-way classification
problem so that's our model for the
training data
the data pruning strategy well what
we're going to do is we're just going to
follow what we did in the Deep learning
in a data type paper we're going to
train a probe student for a short period
of time right so that probe student will
acquire some non-zero dot product of a
teacher
okay and then we're going to compute the
decision boundary of the probe student
and compute the margin of each example
with respect to the probe student
remember we don't have to have direct
access to the teacher we only have
access to training data so we're going
to compute the margins of the training
data with respect to the District
boundary the probe student
okay then we're going to keep the
hardest data with the smallest margins
with respect to this decision about
right so we might keep for example this
example in this example
then we're going to just throw away the
probe and just start trading from
scratch right just like we did before
and then we're going to analytically
compute the test error of a Max margin
learner on the non-gaussian prunes data
okay that's that's the
um strategy we're going to work in the
high dimensional statistics limit where
the dimensionality of the problem goes
to Infinity
the number of examples before you start
pruning goes to Infinity right so the
the density the the ratio of the number
of examples to Dimensions the data
density we're going to call Alpha total
that's going to remain order one
okay and then f is an important
parameter the fraction F of examples
will be key
and so the size of the prunes data set
is by definition F times Alpha total
so that's our um size of the prune data
set and we're going to care about how
performance scale or test error scales
as a function of alpha prune
okay so the important parameters of the
problem are Theta the angle between the
teacher and the probe the projection of
the data onto the probe
um the margin and this and this ratio
now there are certain quantities which
concentrate in this High dimensional
statistics limit and and don't depend on
the detailed realization of the trading
data and so forth one is the cosine
angle between the student and the probe
so the student is the the perceptron
that we train to completion after we do
the pruning that's going to have some
angle with the probe we'll call that
road and it'll have some angle with the
teacher we'll call that R and the test
error is just the inverse cosine angle
of the student with the teacher so if
the student is close to the teacher the
test area of the student is small
okay
right we can write down we can use ideas
from a statistical mechanics of of
disordered systems notably the replica
method to compute self-consistent
equations for these these uh quantities
that concentrate right these happen to
be the equations from these equations we
can extract the tester you don't need to
worry too much about the equations I'll
tell you what the
their consequences
so here's here's an example of a result
so when the okay so this is an example
of when the probe equals the teacher so
Theta is zero right so we have in some
sense the best possible pruning metric
we're pruning according to the
uh the decision amount of the teacher
right uh this horizontal axis is Alpha
prune it's the amount of data we have
after pruning okay this vertical axis is
a test error right these different
curves or corresponding to different
colors correspond to different fractions
of data kept starting from different
Alpha total right
um so for example if you keep a hundred
percent of the data that's like doing no
pruning at all and you get a power law
uh uh scaling of test error with data
set size and that's well known from
plastic perceptron Theory right okay but
now what happens if you plot performance
as a function of alpha prove for
different levels of alpha total and F
right so so remember the relationship
between
there's this relation between Alpha
prune F and Alpha total so there's many
ways to get a particular prone data set
size I could start with lots and lots of
data large Alpha total as small F or I
could start with less data like some
smaller Alpha total and a larger f right
so that's why at any given Alpha prune
there's multiple curves right each curve
eventually settles into a power law so
that corresponds to a fixed pruning
ratio f
right but the Pareto envelope of this
family of Curves falls off as an
exponential and the way you trace this
Peru envelope is you start with larger
and larger data sets and do more
aggressive pruning
a bunch of points
um conditional on them being within
distance like Alpha of uh
um yeah
foreign
classifier with respect to that data
distribution of the um
average a fraction of examples that I
keep yeah getting narrower and narrower
yeah exactly yeah
and by the way like over here you
actually do worse than no pruning at all
so that's an interesting observation
um but in any case uh there is a way
that you can bend the scaling law from a
power law down to an exponential here
and that's by doing
um
uh starting with larger and larger data
sets and doing more and more aggressive
pruning right and then you'll you'll
Trace out this period often Frontier
okay so so this is going back to this
this worst case so here's an example
um it turns out that if you have
not very much data to begin with right
that that's when you have small amounts
of data like small Alpha group
it turns out it's not a good idea to
keep the hardest examples it turns out
it's a better idea to keep the easy
examples and so here's the discrepancy
between the two strategies of keep hard
examples and easy examples and if you
have lots of data to begin with keeping
the hard examples is the better strategy
if you have very little data to begin
with keeping the easy examples of the
better strategy or the perceptron but
this makes an interesting prediction
right
with this same prediction hold for deep
neural networks trained on Benchmark
data sets and remarkably it does right I
think this is the Art of Doing theory is
you work something up for a simple model
and that makes a prediction that
hopefully holds far beyond the regime
the validity of your simple model right
so it turns out in resnet 18 on c410 the
exact same this prediction actually
holds nobody ever looked at uh nobody
meaning we never looked at keeping the
hard examples because always starting
with lots of examples to begin with but
if you artificially reduce your data set
and then prune after that uh it turns
out this is it is indeed a better
strategy so this remarkably the
prediction from perceptron folds in a
much more general setting okay so so
again here's the cartoon picture
uh when you don't have much data to
begin with keep examples of large
margins keep stuff near the poles if you
have lots of data to begin with keep
stuff near the equator
where T is the true regression Vector oh
sorry T is the perceptron okay so um if
you don't have much data then why not
keep all of it
we're trying to understand scaling of um
performance with respect to Optimal data
sets of a given size right and so and
these are non-gaussian data sets so how
do you get that so so we're always
looking at performance reflection the
prune data set size
um
so you do get an efficiency gain of
trading on the smaller data set because
I'm sure
um here's just an advertisement about
another paper where you can analytically
compute the tester for non-gassing data
and actually find the optimal loss of
regularizer but I won't go into that
okay um there's interesting changes that
happen when you when the probe has a
different angle
uh but let's see what can I tell you in
like two minutes that's super fun okay
so just in practice right uh so we tried
this pruning procedure for different uh
problems and we could see that we could
definitely beat the these black scaling
logs right we're not we can't quite get
exponential uh but you can and that's
what that's what would be predicted if
we had an imperfect pruning metric but
you can definitely beat the scaling law
quite significantly uh if you prune the
data uh uh in a certain way right uh it
also works for vision Transformers as
well okay
um
let me uh
yeah so let me just tell you the fun
stuff so we scaled it up to imagenet
there's an interesting algorithm that we
came up with that doesn't even require
labels and when we use that algorithm we
can ask you start to get some intuition
for like what are the easy examples why
are they redundant what are the hard
examples and why is it beneficial to
keep them if you have a lot of examples
to begin with so this is our new pruning
algorithm that works well in imagenet we
can throw away 25 of imagenet without
any decrement in performance and these
are this is just a random class class
100 happens to be Black Swan these are
the easiest examples right the ones that
are learned quickly
and you can see that they're also quite
redundant with each other they're kind
of canonical poses of black swans
the hard examples are the um are all
idiosyncratic and idiosyncratic in their
own way so if you want to do well on
imagenet you can throw away a lot of
these but you got to keep bees
another example is that another random
costs 200 right
um Tibetan Terrier these are the easy
examples they're all kind of canonical
redundant these are the hard examples
they're all kind of idiosyncratic right
including weird color Maps here
and then the fun one the tiger beetle
again the easy examples are here here's
a really hard here's a hard example
which is a cartoon of a tiger beetle
right like there's this just all gets
algorithm picked out so this is a great
way to like kind of explore your data
set yeah
potentially I mean I'd also say they're
quite similar to each other there's more
of them
they're just more beagle in the picture
yeah yeah the reason I say they're more
similar is that the algorithm we use for
getting this was to put all of these
images into the embedding space of a
foundation model
cluster them into clusters and take the
examples that are furthest from the
cluster centroids so all of these images
are closest to their respective cluster
centroid so they're all quite similar to
each other as measured by euclidean
distance in the embedding space of the
foundation model sure when they're all
more similar to each other they have
more beetle in them but I think it's a
similarity that's more important
that yeah
I mean the similarity is what what
allowed us to pick these off
we have no mathematical notion of more
Beetle that would ever played into their
selection of these
okay uh just again uh we also figured
out a way to this lion data set 440
million images we could scale it that we
could prune it down to half its size so
220 million without suffering any loss
in performance and then you train twice
as fast so when you start to be able to
train Foundation models twice as fast
you start to save of course time and
money
um we can also get like 15 efficiency
gains on language models uh anyway those
details are here and I'll just stop uh
right there
and let's just take those questions
thank you
um so when
when you prune your data based on like
the probe State that's fairly early on
in training well that like bias your
like ultimate training results to like
look more like the probe State and have
you considered that in terms of like the
efficiency gain model training by doing
data proving this way
yeah um
yeah this is kind of the philosophy
behind how model uh data printing can be
um
useful uh but but
we so we looked for
the we looked for biases in the
in the image act classifier train on the
prune data side so we looked at to do
certain does it do worse in certain
classes than others and if you don't
class balance it does right but if you
class balance you get rid of that
now in the in the situation where we
train the lion data set where we don't
have labels we do have captions when we
ignored the captions we did the pruning
and then we looked at the image at
classifier we didn't see biases right
when we use the we trained a clip model
on Lion we did a linear readout to train
an imagenet classifier on top of the
lion uh embedding space and we looked at
the biases of that image at classifier
and we didn't see any biases by pruning
on clip
right so
I think it depends if you're pruning on
the same data distribution that you're
training on you might have to worry
about biases but if you're not you don't
at least in these limited set of
experiments aren't they making sense
thank you I think you mentioned this
briefly we talked about the Pareto
envelope and sorry if I missed more of
it but don't those curves also allow you
to infer like Optimal curriculum
depending on data set size potentially
yeah we were kind of looking at just a
One-Shot pruning strategy right right
you could imagine all sorts of
modifications where you you train a
little bit you prune you train a little
bit you prune and so forth
um you could even imagine sequencing the
data points according to their
difficulty we didn't explore any of that
stuff we the the One-Shot pruning is is
nice because it needs this notion of a
foundation data set right like you have
this huge lion data set that a bunch of
people are training on if you can find
one subset that's just as good as the
entire data set we can just hand that
out as a foundation data set and
everybody can train on that instead
right it doesn't require people to
optimize the hyper parameters of
curriculum learning or Active Learning
or so forth which is a harder problem
like something that is a bit unclear to
me is how much this pruning technique
really is based on the discriminative
nature of the task so if you have the
generative task I'm not really sure that
this type of throwing of the data would
um save
um I feel that it's kind of like doing
part of the work of optimization instead
of confusing the model to go to the
direction you basically put on the data
so that the model can go faster to a
certain direction during an organization
do you think this technique would
transfer to a generative task where you
want to replicate a distribution
basically yeah we haven't uh it's a
really good question we have not looked
at uh data pruning for training
generative models
we definitely haven't looked at that I
don't know uh it's an open empirical
question
um
you could imagine certain data fitting
procedures and distributions
that might not hurt the final input
output map of the generative model so
it's conceivable that it could work but
it's an empirical question whether it
will or not okay let's uh thank cereal
once again and uh go straight to the
book
and we'll meet back here in about 15
minutes